all right welcome back uh i guess to
myself i'm back from los angeles i was
on the joe rogan
experience one of the world's biggest
podcasts and youtube shows
thanks to ben dixon who filled in for me
on sort of short notice i mean it came
the joe rogan thing came together pretty
quickly i didn't even know
that i was going to be going to los
angeles this week
until the day i believe it was that i
was leaving
on the end of may break which had been
planned a long time in advance so
thanks to everybody who understands that
this was a big opportunity and i didn't
intend to immediately leave the show
again so quickly after that that brief
break at the end of may
i also i guess should thank all the
trolls for those nice messages
leading up to the interview david you're
going to bomb i can't wait to see joe
rogan
wipe the floor with you you're going to
embarrass yourself and all of that stuff
and the funny thing
sort of is that when someone sends a
message like that i actually wonder if
that person has never seen
rogan's show or maybe has never seen my
show because
rogan has long-form conversations with
people
and owning or whatever is not really his
thing i mean sometimes people do end up
getting exposed on his show as we've
pointed out like
when candace owens or dave rubin go on
there or
ben shapiro goes on and says things that
don't make any sense but
in any case i think it went really well
overall
i'm very self-critical and in watching
it back after the fact
i don't think i handled every aspect of
the two plus hour conversation
as well as i would have wanted or maybe
would have if i had known in advance
exactly what the topics would be but
that's the whole thing it's sort of an
unplanned informal long-form
conversation
and i know that i'm a huge self-critic
many areas for
improvement would have liked to have
been more clear in some areas but
it was really a great opportunity for
the show it's already had a nice impact
on the show nice boost on youtube
nice boost on podcast subscribers
modest paid membership boost although
the thing about that is it takes a while
to convert a new viewer to a member
since you don't immediately become a
paid member of a show
as soon as you hear about it most people
don't anyway
you hear about a show then you watch it
or listen to it for a while
and then some portion of those people
later become paid members so my
my hope is that in the next four to 12
weeks we'll convert
a lot of that new audience into paid
subscribers and that'll be a really
great thing
um also had a great dinner with destiny
and hassan [ __ ] and my manager
who all of whom are out in los angeles
there are some pictures
on my instagram from that i was on
another show while in l.a called
exploring minds with michelle carroll
who's an actress who also now has
an interview show and i had about an
hour conversation with her it hasn't
been published yet i think it will be
pretty soon and i posted a picture from
that behind the scenes picture
of michelle and of me on the instagram
account so check it out overall
huge huge win in the battle of ideas
there were moments on the rogan show
where joe and i disagreed and i think
those were some of the best moments and
it was fine and it was not awkward and
it was as respectful as i imagined that
it would be
uh we talked about what constitutes a
homophobic slur
in the context of youtube's terms of
service in terms of conditions how to
figure out whether a company is liberal
or conservative
and we had disagreements and uh it was
it was absolutely great to have them
and i i hope that it was productive in a
sense for the audience
so hi to everyone who has learned about
this show over the last three days sorry
i guess to everybody who was waiting for
my appearance on joe rogan to go so
poorly to be such an embarrassment to
just such a shameful face plant that it
would decimate the david pakman show
um i apologize if that's what you were
expecting onward and upward
to more things and expansion and more
announcements coming soon
um i did unfortunately have to mute
hundreds of people
on twitter after these appearances
because of the amount
of just vitriolic trolling
but my new approach is i don't even
think about engaging with the nonsense
on twitter or social media i see it i
mute it
i don't have to think about it again and
i strongly strongly advise
uh other people in the audience to do
the same thing
unfortunately some of the people in the
audience are the ones doing the trolling
and so they probably won't take that
advice but if you're a good faith actor
on social media
i'm telling you i am doing much better
uh in terms of everything productivity
focus
uh concentrating on the right things
over the noise
since i have just started this policy of
no engagement with trolls
mute them don't think about them again
that's that's my advice to you